[Music]
welcome honored guests
my name is wednesday adams i live in
this house
the addams mansion with the rest of my
family let me show you around
this is the main entry hall me and my
brother pugsley find it useful to
practice sword fighting here
this is lurch's he sometimes plays for
us when we sit in the great room
[Music]
that's the door to the basement in
granny's kitchen we can't go down there
now
she's canning the neighbors what is she
doing
just a curse have a nice day
[Music]
through here is my father's study
i sometimes use this place to spy on
conniving people this is the
conservatory where alert sometimes plays
and mother grows plants and throws
parties what
oh i didn't say anything no that's the
baby's nickname
what this is the nursery
this is where that thing lives this is
its cradle
this is where it sleeps this is its
mobile
we hope it falls why do you hate the
baby
we don't hate him we just want to play
with him especially his head
if you notice there's a theme to this
wall a theme we hope will communicate
itself to the baby
oh gomez it's dark it's depressing
this is the upstairs hallway it leads to
all the bedrooms
this is the nanny's room this is mr
linsky our new nanny
what do we say be afraid be very
afraid notice the bars we wouldn't want
that woman running free through our
house
this is where she sleeps if she sleeps
good night scream if you need anything
this stereo leads up to the third floor
and the tower me and my brother pugsley
find this useful for throwing anvils
down on
guests
[Music]
this is mother and father's room this is
where they sleep
this is mother's vanity sometime thing
gives her a manicure here
good show old man
this is my room this is my bed it's kind
of barren because we're remodeling
pugsley what all right i'm going
i'm going
i bet sometimes you wish it was still
just the two of you
or less
you've seen our house now i'm going to
show you our backyard
welcome to the cemetery a lot of adam's
people are buried here great uncles
great aunts
cousins
and soon brothers i'm watching tales
from the crit
i hope you've enjoyed your tour and i
hope you come back and see us again
[Music]
soon